It is time for hatred that male hatred, male,
of course, a a favorite moment of the week
for many in the audience, although a stressful
moment for some. I do get emails from people
saying that they are sickened by the ignorance
of hatred. Male, what is hatred? Mail? Quick
reminder.
So what if the president's been accused of
sexual Harrison 15 times or that he paid hush
money to a porn star? At least he never wore
a tan suits. Hey, [inaudible] [inaudible]
written by Patriots who hate David Pacman
because America and because freedom,
this week's hatred mail has, you know, yesterday
I interviewed PE Moscowitz about how often
frequent, how frequently people are misunderstanding
the concept of free speech. That is a big
part of this week's hatred mail. Let's take
a listen.
David Parkman does like to lie. Hey man, you
David Parkman for deleting my comment so you
don't allow free speech. Why did you delete
the biggest Colts of personnel? Eat are around
you, not Trump. David Parkman show you are
in a [inaudible]. No. My president Donald
Trump, 2020 we see you in the arena. America
is first is Donald Trump 2020
yeah. I mean, listen, first of all there's
like a practical question here which is I
get emails all the time from people saying,
David, you're censoring me. Why are you deleting
my comments? I can assure you I am very, very
busy hosting and researching the David Pakman
show, running the business side of the David
Pakman show and working on the ad agency side
of the David Pakman show and and our organization.
I can't sit around and look at and delete
individual YouTube comments. It's flattering
that someone, it's quaint that someone would
think I have the time to do that, but I don't
and staff does also also does not delete YouTube
comments. If people are seeing YouTube comments
deleted, it's because other viewers are flagging
them either as spam or attacks or whatever,
and I don't even know how the YouTube algorithm
works around this, but some number of flags
must get comments removed, but I have no idea
what is going on there.
Number two, come on. You have no right to
leave comments on my YouTube channel. It's
not an issue of free speech. You have no right
to show up on my personal Twitter page or
my personal Instagram account and leave antisemitic
insults and whatever else. If I want to block
you, if I want to mute you, and I admit I
have thousands of people muted on Twitter
because it is just an echo chamber cesspool,
it is not an issue of free speech and you
should really rethink that entire thing. Remember
that the best way to fight hatred, autism
in your local community is to get a membership@joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code hatred 40 the coupon
hood code hatred 40 accomplishes two just
beautiful things. One, it supports the David
Pakman show and too, it's sort of like a middle
finger to the hatred. It's that you will not
be intimidated by their hatred.
Autism, that's hatred. 40 H. a. T, R I, O.
T. four zero saves you 40% and a thousand
hatred cry every time the coupon code is used.